let's go to our caller from the nine one
two area code who's calling today from
nine one two hello David
I'm Sebastian from Savannah I was an
article on box from Zack pal champ about
his change of mine on impeachment he
stated that his inquiry about the
inquiry is about what is happening
currently and in the future 2020
election this impeachment is about what
he's doing right now the previous calls
in for impeachment were for the mother
probe were about previous actions and
did not merit impeachment I know your
take on this is different but it is
quite compelling for me for the
justification of impeachment now thank
you for taking my call David sorry so
whose opinion is this are you reading
someone else's opinion I didn't hear who
it was yeah this is from a an opinion
from Zac Bal champ from Vox okay alright
and he says that this is different than
previous calls for impeachment because
it's about Trump's current actions
rather than previous actions exactly he
says that because this is happening
right now and within like it's within
our it's right in front of us and we
have the evidence right in front of us
that we do have impeachment and to me it
is a pretty justification for
impeachment because there's no question
as it is all need you need the inquiry
to explore whether an impeachment trial
is the right next step and then the
Senate needs to vote so I think you are
100% right or mr. Zack Beauchamp is is
right in pointing out that this relates
to something that is now like this
relate you know it's been the last three
months that this Ukraine stuff has been
going on that doesn't give us the answer
as to whether it is something the
president should be removed from office
for that's why we're starting this
process but I agree that that's a key
difference from the Moller stuff which
was trying to figure out what took place
back in 2015 and 2016 yeah and I
understood your take on both leader
original opinion on this new impeachment
and I knew that this would be a little
bit different but this is the only
impeachment inquiry right I mean this is
the wit there was
well did calls for impeachment with the
world of calls for impeachment you know
I remember you know how Democrats were
trying to say you know they wanted
impeachment because the Moller probe and
you're saying it is that's not happening
yeah it's and there's no way it's going
to happen but with this this is
completely diff all right Sebastian
point well made I appreciate you making
it and I hope to hear from you again in
the future